today we're going to look at how we
could recreate the Invisible Man titles
in After Effects like you see here let's
get
[Music]
started he everyone my name is cam with
motion science and I recently came
across a post on Instagram from Deva or
Diva Studios where they showed the
Invisible Man titles that they
previously had created and I thought it'
be fun to recreate these in After
Effects and what we're going to do today
but before we dive in and get started I
want to tell you really quickly that if
you're interested in creating work like
you see here on my channel which I call
cinematic motion design there's a
technique to it where we apply a lot of
organic techniques and I have a free
guide that you can download over at
motion science.
tvguide uh it's a free pdf guide it's
going to give you my tips and tricks for
how to create organic motion design like
you see on the channel so definitely go
check it out after you watch this video
motion sign science.
tvguide you'll love it all right so
let's jump into after effects and let's
see how I would recreate the Invisible
Man titles just here in After Effects no
3D application needed first thing we're
going to do is we're going to create a
new composition and it's an
httv 1080 24 frames per second comp
we're going to make it 4 seconds so it's
pretty short click okay and the first
thing we're going to do is create a
background solid so we'll go to layer
new solid and I found that I really
liked this pale red solid color here uh
it's not Pure White it's just got a
little bit of a red tin to it we're
going to click okay and we're going to
call
this
background perfect next thing we need to
do is we need to create the Invisible
Man type so I'm going to type out
the and we can't see it yet because it's
all in the same colors our background so
Invisible Man and we're going to select
all
that and there it is the Invisible Man
first thing we're going to do is we're
going to line horizontally and align
vertically and then we're going to
change this to a very simple thin tight
face and I found that I liked the den
and there's light but we're actually
going to select extra light here and
we're going to drop this to about 150
and we're going to also drop the leting
let's try 150 for that
and for this vertical tracking we're
going to expand this let's try a number
like 200 and that's a little bit too
much so let's drop it down to 150 and
again we'll we will align horizontally
and align vertically that looks pretty
good to me now the next thing we need to
do is we need to make this
3D and we want to give this some
Extrusion like we've seen in a 3D
program so how do we do that so the
first thing we're going to do is we're
going to go to our composition settings
and we're going to go to 3D renderer and
we're going to change it from classic 3D
to Cinema 40 and click okay and nothing
changes at this point but if we scroll
open our type and go down here to
Geometry options we can extrude this
right here with Extrusion depth so we'll
turn this up to say 50 and again you can
tell there's a little bit going on if I
change to two views at this point and we
zoom in we can see there's some depth
here and let's just turn on bevel style
and we'll just make it angular and we're
not going to play around too much with
that and again looks okay but we can
make this look way more interesting by
adding a light so we'll go to layer new
light and we're going to change it from
ambient to
Spotlight and let's turn the intensity
up to 100% and cash Shadows is on sure
great and let's also make the background
layer a 3D layer and now we've got a a
light happening so let's go into back to
our type and under material options we
need to make sure that cash Shadows is
ticked on now if we pull this light back
you can see that Shadows are starting to
be cast now so I'm going to undo that
and I'm going to switch this back to a
left view so I can see my light here I'm
going to pull this light up going to
zoom out here pull it up and I'm going
to rotate it down hit R for rotation and
I'm going to rotate it down and I'm
going to bring it closer to the
wall kind of bring it up like this
I'm hit R for
rotation and I'm going to bring it at a
little bit of an angle like
so and then again I'm just playing
around with the EXP position kind of
bringing it over to the
right I'm just going to fine te that
position and I'm also going to bring in
a another light a second light and we're
going to create an ambient light and
we're going to turn the intensity down
to about 15% and this just gives the
scene a little bit overall brightness we
can see things a little bit better just
like that and again it doesn't look
super interesting but if we set a key
frame for our position and let's set it
at 3 seconds here and we go to the
beginning here and we bring It
Forward then under the spotlight I'm
also going to turn down the shadow
diffusion so it's not so soft we're
going to take it down to something like
10 and you can see now we're starting to
get some interesting Shadows let's also
go ahead and make that type white and
I'm going to f tune the position just a
little bit more by playing around with
the point of interest and there we go so
it's looking really nice at this point
and if I preview
this you can see the type starts
extruded out and it's pulling back and
we'll switch to half reses here and
here's our preview and you can see that
the type is just it's pulling back it's
disappearing into the wall wall which is
what I was going for here it's looking
really nice the Shadows are also kind of
dropping down dropping an intensity as
the type is moving back now the type
doesn't compl completely disappear here
so let's set a key frame for
transparency and we'll move that just a
few frames forward and we'll make sure
that at this point it's completely gone
now you can see there's a weird artifact
happening here where the Invisible Man
is still there and I'm not quite sure
why that is uh sometimes there's some
weird anomalies that happen inside of
After Effects so we'll come back to this
it's it's weird I can turn off the type
turn it back on and it's still there so
I'm not sure what's going on if I turn
the lights off it's still there very
bizarre anyways we'll come back to that
and fix it as needed so let's go ahead
and add a camera to give this a little
bit more movement and we'll go with the
35mm camera click okay P for position
set the key frame go to the end of our
timeline
and we'll back back it out just a little
bit and let's go ahead and scale up our
background so that it's always in the
frame perfect now one thing I noticed
about the example that D.A Studios did
is that as these letters were
disappearing they didn't all disappear
at the exact same time there was a few
of them that were still there kind of
lingering and then they would disappear
so that makes the animation that much
more interesting and it's all about
these subtleties so that's what we want
to do next so to do that I'm going to
select the type I'm going to open up
the text and animate I'm going to enable
per character 3D so that each individual
character is treated as its own thing
and then we're also going to add a
position animator to this and we're
going to open up uh position Advanced
and we're going to change this from
Square to Triangle and E's High we're
going to take it 100 we're also going to
click randomize order and give it a
simple value here things just disappear
slightly differently so they don't all
all go off as one unit it just makes it
a little bit more visually interesting
but we'll try a random seed also we'll
try putting in a one that's nice we can
also try cranking the two up to a four
see what that does and let's try
previewing that it looks good so again
that anomaly is it's still happening
it's happening right here so what I'm
going to do is I'm just going to go
ahead and cut this layer so option
bracket so layer ends maybe right here
yeah see it's weird it's happening right
there so we're just going to end our
animation right there let's also go
ahead and add an
opacity and we'll set this to zero as
well and we'll back it
up so again I'm just trying to make
this transition out as smooth as
possible and I found in my testing that
it was all a matter of fine tuning these
little adjustments with the text
animators so see that already looks a
little bit nicer I just want it to be
really smooth as it goes out may even
back it up just a little bit
more and we're going to bring the other
fade out right here just a little bit
quicker right at the end just to make
this as smooth as possible here at the
end it's just all about tweaking these
little
nuances this is what makes or breaks a
professional piece so let's finish this
piece just like I've been finishing a
lot of other pieces lately and that was
with a new adjustment layer and we're
going to use the film emulation plugin
from dehancer Pro and I absolutely love
the Fuji color 100 and I'm also going to
enable vignette and let's also just
let's go ahead and bump this up to full
reses and let's give this just a hair of
color here so color correction CC toner
which is one of my favorites to use I'm
going to bring that up
before the dehancer plugin and I'm going
to change the midtones here to kind of
like a bluish white click okay and there
we go that is the recreation of the
Invisible Man titles I hope that you
found this tutorial insightful and you
learned something new about the
possibilities of 3D uh in After Effects
while using Extrusion and lights I want
to remind you to go check out my free
pdf guide the guide to mastering organic
motion design it's absolutely free
motion science. tvguide go get it and uh
as always thanks for watching and I'll
see you in the next
[Music]
video